man: So a little about the--
a little bit about WeatherBug
as a company and who we are.
Um, WeatherBug is
a weather information provider
as you can probably guess
by our name.
And what makes us different
is that we have a network
of weather stations.
We have
around 8,000 weather stations
across the United States.
500 in Canada.
And those weather stations
produce live real-time
information
for your neighborhood.
So we also gather data
from airports,
but, you know,
the WeatherBug network makes it
much more granular information
for your neighborhood.
We also have cameras
on a certain number
of those weather stations,
about 1,500 cameras.
And we also added lightning
detection to our network
just this past year.
And we hope to build
the most accurate
lightning detection network
that's available.
man: So you chose the Android
platform to create this app.
Tell us a bit about how you came
to the technical decision
to do that.
man: So we chose
Android platform to build
our WeatherBug application,
you know, mainly,
for WeatherBug,
since the data's very local,
and when you're out
walking around with your mobile
phone and you want to get
the most accurate weather
information, um,
you know, we wanted to be able
to provide live real-time data
to the application.
So we built, you know,
a native application that runs
on Android.
The data updates
every few seconds.
You can get maps,
you can get
your hourly forecast,
your daily forecast,
directly from the phone.
It's able to run
in the background on a phone
and so that we can send
severe weather alerts
directly to the phone,
so no matter where you travel,
it uses location-based portions
of the phone
to automatically gather
your location
and automatically send you
severe weather alerts
based on that location.
man: Yeah, and it's that
the strategy is mobile, right,
because weather is something
you really can take mobile.
And when a new platform
like Android comes out,
it's obvious--
it's an obvious choice.
It's also--we can do
powerful stuff
on a platform like Android.
man: Uh, what specific tips
and tricks did you use
in your application?
You mentioned the temperature...
man: Oh, yeah. Yeah.
man: Any other tics--
tips or tricks?
man: Tips and tricks.
Um...
I'm not sure what--
I guess the notification, right?
We came up with a, I guess,
maybe not that clever, right,
but using the alarm manager
so we don't use
any battery at all.
The application starts up,
hands it off
to the notification system,
and forgets about it.
And the next time
the application needs to update,
it will start up.
And, of course, I think maybe,
maybe, sort of,
a major thing is our UI.
We think we came up
with a good idea for--
so you have a very map-centric
view where you can easily switch
between locations.
So I think maybe the way
we do the location switching
and the maps
and then stuff like that.
man: Yeah.
man:
Uh, what's your favorite aspect
of the Android development
process?
man: Well, the favorite aspect
is it's Java.
We love Java.
And also that it's so easy.
Um, it's very easy to set up,
and it's very easy
to get started.
So I would say, uh...
And also
that it's a powerful platform.
You can do--you can do
whatever you want to do.
And, I mean,
if you have an idea
to develop something,
it's--you sort of--
I don't know how
to express this,
but you can do--
for instance,
we do a lot on very simple
phones
that's very limited--it's very
limited what you can do.
So you always have
this trade-off.
On Android, of course,
at some point,
you have a--you can--
there's some speed
and some screen size factors,
but, you know,
it's a powerful device.
man: It's a great phone
for getting your app out
with the market, you know,
being--
being able to be front
and center and, for everybody
that has the phone, to be able
to just get your app
and get immediate feedback
from people.
I mean,
we have amazing customers
that have downloaded it
and given us feedback.
And, you know, we're able
to react to that
and add features
and fix bugs or whatever it is
that people report to us,
so it's been
a great platform to develop on.
man: And a good point
is the market
because as soon as we have
a new release,
we just upload that application,
and it's available
to the user right away.
And that is not something
you can do with other markets
or platforms.
man: Yeah.
man: Uh, are there any features
that you can do
in your app that you can't do
on other platforms?
man: Uh, any features
that we can do in this app
that you can't do
on other platforms we have?
Um, now less,
but in the beginning,
the Android application was
actually sort of the template
for all our applications.
Now we have other platforms
like Windows Mobile
and iPhone.
So, um...
so, yeah, it laid the groundwork
for the other applications.
man: Yup, user interface-wise,
the ease of building
the user interface, I think,
and all the elements
behind that are what
kind of gave us our impetus
to what we're developing
across the board really
for all of
our mobile applications.
So...
man: Yeah, and then, of course,
the widgets--
the widgets we don't have
on--
man: Sure.
man: We have, but not
in that way, yeah.
Temperature next to the clock.
We don't have that
on all platforms,
so that is also
an Android-specific thing.
We try to do it, but not all
the platforms can do it.
man: Correct. Yeah.
man: Yeah.
man: All right, gentlemen, well,
I appreciate your time today.
man: Absolutely.
man: And I hope you have
a wonderful conference.
man: Yeah.
It's a great conference. Thanks.